how're you doing I'm good how are you
we're talking about Goodfellas huh
so my favor I think this is my favorite
film yeah it's up there I showed him to
my son recently who's 13 and I had to
get him to close his eyes every once in
a while but he loved it
do you I have had this conversation with
people some people prefer casino to
Goodfellas and I'm like seems good but
Goodfellas is like next-level now cuz he
knows a little long so in Goodfellas is
too tight it's a tight tight movie
you can't stop watch they were done it
every time it's on it's it's it's
amazing yeah there's no there's no weak
link in that film but we are off on a
tangent perfect I want to jump in I want
to jump in 2003 where those teachers uh
first of all I want to say congrats on
the film oh thank you um it is really
hard to do like this kind of tone where
it's like funny but there's serious
action and you try to keep it grounded
talk a little about the challenges of
walking that line um I think the first
thing you gotta do is is keep the
performances honest like keep keep all
of the performances even the comedy like
just keep trying to keep everybody
honest not too broad not too big just
sort of keep it keep it simple and and
don't don't try to like hammer for the
joke too much and I think with the
action in the comedy I think they
complement each other very well I think
when you do action very fast and
visceral it can go full circle into
comedy and if you layer in a lot of
mistakes into the action and you make it
feel sloppy and real I think people feel
like yeah it adds it and adds an element
of comedy to the action so in terms of
keeping that that tone I think they all
sort of feed into each other and it's
just about sort of overseeing and making
sure that we never get too broad and
that that tonally it's it's consistent
like so you're not making crazy jokes or
jokes it just aren't aren't this film
you know what I mean and many times that
can be that can get get out of hand but
it's just sort of overriding that as a
director and making sure that everything
is is intone you open it's like a James
Bond opening you got to yeah you got the
serious opening action set piece sure
was it always that way
what do you mean like opening with an
action set piece yes yeah from the
script I wanted to start the movie and
established that telling me to talking
right away and just and separate this
film from some of the other action
comedies by saying okay buckle up we're
gonna we're gonna set a set of tone and
a pace here and this is gonna be a
pretty violent movie so so yeah it was
by design but it was also also you want
to sort of draw people into the story
and just like a James Bond movie with
sure I'm obsessed with the editing
process because that's the final rewrite
sure uh what did you learn in the
editing room when you first got in there
and what did test screenings maybe teach
you about the film oh really good
question the first thing I learned was
that we didn't need as many driving
scenes is that just the way we shot the
film we shot most of in Atlanta and then
we came out here and shot a lot of the
daylight driving stuff cuz I didn't want
to use green screen or anything and I
wanted to feel that feel the city you
know LA wanted to be a character in this
movie so I saw cut of the movie with
none of the driving sequences in it and
then it was like we got a good got a
good movie and then we put all the
driving sequences in and it was like I
got to pull some of those out because
it's not they're not as needed as much I
think with editing it's all it's all
about pulling out exposition it's about
is it's about fine-tuning it and if
you've said something once you don't
need to say it again or if she's
establishes something no you don't need
to watch somebody else learn that
information so many times scripts are a
little bit more expository just because
it's a written form it's not visual so
it's just dialing it back and
fine-tuning the comedy oh it's gonna say
and you obviously do test screenings
yeah yeah what did you learn from those
test readings and did it impact the
finished film uh I scored great right
off my director's cut so I learned just
to keep making it tighter and make it
even better so basically you went home
super happy that I went a super yeah
it's a rare experience guys there's been
a lot where it hasn't happened like that
but uh no it's it's so important for a
comedy to show it get in front of a
crowd even before the test screening the
official test screening just put it up
in front of 30 or 40 people just feel
the pace of the movie and you know I
think my biggest critique of a lot of
movies right now is that they're usually
20 minutes too long and I just want I
wanted this film to be
tight you know what was the last thing
that you cut out of the film the last
deleted scene that almost made the film
a really good question we used to have a
title sequence opening title sequence
which was based around kumail's
or Stu's night as an uber driver and
what we realized is that the movie
really starts once Camille and Dave are
in the car together so that was the last
big cut is that we've excised that
credit sequence was just probably a
minute and a half and just made it a
sort of thirty twenty to thirty second
montage you're just getting a sense of
Stu's life is an over driver I'm curious
what will be eventually it's gonna be on
blu-ray home video yeah do you have a
lot of deleted scenes that will be on
the blu-ray not a ton no not a ton
there's a there's one of the couple of
driving sequences I mentioned there's
one little scene with Mira where they're
talking about tej Oh a little bit they
know there's not a ton there's there's a
lot of alts so there's there's a there's
a there's a collection of sort of the
jokes that didn't make it in which is
pretty funny and some of them are
fantastic but for reasons we couldn't
put them in but they're but they're like
the the bastard child but they're
they're still funny in their own right
that that's the thing that I find when
you have these two guys together I would
imagine you have you know the a B and C
version that are all really good and
then which one do you pick ya know it's
it's it's almost like a play off the
system where you almost work with
brackets and you compare and see how
they work and sometimes a and you see it
actually a lot in the marketing
sometimes the joke works by itself but
it doesn't work for the entire film
so it's it's finding out like it's a
funny joke but it's at the cost of a
character it's at the cost of something
else that that affects the greater film
so there's a bunch of different
processes but I we like to I like to
audition the the jokes and see if I've
got one two or three a B and C you put
them up in front of a crowd and see how
they play because you never know you get
surprised by things all the time
completely um Dave is able Dave is
really good on camera and he is able to
like
thread that line of action star funny it
doesn't it's a real talent that he has
what surprised you when you were working
with him on set about what he could do I
think the most surprising thing for me
was his heart was what he brought to the
end of the film in terms of his ability
to show emotion to show the character
has changed and to draw a heart out of
it I mean that that along with the
comedy as well obviously he was funny
he's shown that before but just how
funny he is in this movie and and how
tight his timing is and how good is it
improvising but yeah it's probably the
heart and the improvising my last
question for you I know you you already
did another movie after this like coffee
and cream coffee and cream right what
can you tease people about that film and
when will be be when will we I'd
literally wrapped it two days ago 5 in
the morning it's it is profane it is
about a it's about a Detroit a white
Detroit cop who's having any who's in a
new relationship with a single
african-american mother and the son
forgets his iPad comes home and
witnesses the white cop sleeping with
his mother and puts a hit out on the
white cop so it's it's an action comedy
again it's sort of all I know they're
all in one night sort of film but it's
it's anchored by a 12 year old kid who's
incredible who's you're you're about to
find out a lot more more about